chapter six hire slowly but fire
quickly in 2003 I was working for
Canada's largest collection agency where
I was well into my fourth year of
service as a manager to a team doing $2
million in
receivables my staff were well trained
and loyal which meant our recovery rates
were incredible earlier that year I had
a new vice president assigned to our
group French Canadian guy from a very
rough background I remember him telling
us stories about his childhood and how
his father shot himself in the face he
clashed with me from the GetGo he would
publicly disrespect me in front of my
staff and make me run detailed reports
which he never looked at for his own
personal
Amusement after a few months of putting
up with his disrespect something snapped
inside of me and I let him know what I
thought of him thanks this is where I
learned the valuable lesson that people
get hired for their skills and resume
but get fired for fit towards the end of
the year only three weeks after I moved
into my first house with a big mortgage
a manager salary needed to come off the
books for corporate cost cutting yes who
was selected by my loving vice president
to go home
me the initial burn of being handed that
severance package hurt but this push
inspired me to go create my own business
which helped me settle consumer credit
card debt and I will forever be thankful
for that it was about a decade later
when I finally learned the lesson to
hire slowly and fire quickly in my own
business you can use this idea with
women in your life employees business
partners and even
friends take your time vetting people
get to know them and study their
behavior the choices someone makes and
how they behave should always Trump what
they tell you if there's a conflict
between actions and words for example
don't listen to what they say watch what
they do if your Spidey senses tingle
listen to your intuition it knows
something is up intuition is the little
voice whispering in your ear and it
often only becomes a loud shout when
it's too late and you're going to
experience a train
wreck my single mommy
experience shortly after my divorce I
got involved with a single mom of two
boys and for the first few months it was
great fun dating her after a few short
months she started suggesting that I
meet her boys this was when my intuition
sted whispering to me telling me it
wasn't a good idea but I ignored it of
course my intuition only became a shout
when her older son manufactured
indignation he started throwing a bad
hissy fit yelling at me and calling me
names because I enforced a boundary with
them that they didn't like8 months after
I met them their mother sided with the
bratty Behavior completely ignoring the
fact that I was right in hindsight I
should have limited my time in that
relationship to just her and let it run
its course I never should have become
involved with her kids I should have
also quickly fired her ass and ended the
relationship with her at that point and
then moved on but I let the torture drag
on for nearly two more years I also
endured several similar incidents
because I again ignored my intuition it
ended in a colossal train wreck for me
with a severe case of oneitis when she
cheated on me after I tried to enforce
boundaries with her kids again
the business partner
experience shortly after I took my
severance package and went home I
partnered with a friend of mine I used
to work with to offer debt relief
services to Consumers he still had a job
that paid him very well so I was doing
almost all of the work and he was taking
half the money out of the business
account every month I was working
exceptionally hard to make it work we
were making about $30,000 a month for a
business with only two staff and no
overhead so it initially felt
amazing that was until I realized that
my partner had a drug problem and was a
control
freak my intuition was telling me to get
out but once again I didn't listen it
wasn't until 8 months later when it
became a literal shout in my head and
only when my business partner was
screaming at me over my insistence for
him to quit his job and join me
full-time in a full-blown state of
Hysteria he began yelling at me that he
never put me on the corporate books and
that I technically don't exist in the
business initially it ended very badly
but I picked myself back up quickly and
with my brother formed what would become
Canada's most successful debt settlement
company anytime I've gotten into trouble
with women employees business partners
or anything else it was because I didn't
listen to my intuition and fire that
person from my life quick enough with
women friends employees and business
associates always hire slowly and Fire
fast you must be fastidious with your
time and who you allow Into Your Inner
Circle the cold hard truth never forget
it's incumbent on you to okay so that's
uh the cold heart truth part of the book
is really just a summary of the chapter
which I can skip
over um I talked a lot about intuition
in that chapter and I've never really
done much on these podcast shows dealing
with that
um I frame it in the book as this little
voice it's a you know it's a whisper um
using that as an example it could be
dealing with a woman that is problematic
maybe she's got red flags but at some
point there's going to be a little voice
in your head even if you haven't read
the chapter on red flags where most
people that are tuned in especially as
you get older and you get duped and
people [__] you over and you know they
they take advantage of you they might uh
could be financially or any other way or
they mislead you um you start having
this gut reaction and it's like I said
in the book it's like this little voice
that's like hey man you might want to
pay attention to this um you know she's
hanging out with that ex-boyfriend of
hers and she's having coffee with him
hey man she's got a lot of male friends
hey man you know she likes to go out and
party a lot you know that little voice
that's your gut that's your intuition
and it's whispering to you the problem
is is that we suck at listening to it we
think we know better we think that and
again you know it it could be because we
think we know better it could be because
we're thinking with the wrong head but
you proceed anyway and Chaos generally
ensues and
it will ensue at some point if your
intuition is picking up on something um
getting good at listening to your gut
isn't that difficult of a skill you all
have it you got it I got it we all got
it we all
have a vibe that picks up on [__] that
can damage hurt or even kill us you know
um so Call It Whatever you will your
guardian angel your intuition your gut
whatever it happens to be most people
will ignore it when it
Whispers we can't ignore it when it
becomes a shout I couldn't ignore it
when that G I was dating that had two
kids from her prior marriage in toe and
you know the kid was throwing a hissy
fit having a spaz calling me names and
all this sort of [__] you can't ignore
that then you're then you're confronted
with dealing with it and as I've stated
many times and I covered in you know my
book women that have children they're
not going to side with you they're of
think going aside with the kids Brad
Behavior not always 100% of the time but
the vast majority of women that's how
they respond so using your intuition in
relationships in business transactions
in uh if you're an employer if you're an
employee if you're dealing with friends
if you're dealing with uh anything that
you're building with people Associates
businesses Partnerships it doesn't
matter listen to it what is it what is
it telling you um a couple of friends of
mine they like to journal and they'll
just Journal down you know ideas during
the day that's that's one way to do it
you know some people you know they'll
they'll make audio notes uh all phones
now have a voice recorder uh it's
actually called voice recorder on
Android phones um and you know you can
make audio notes um you know sort of
journaling what your guts picking up on
use these tools in life to evaluate and
assess uh and and and hone it because in
hindsight it's 100% accurate you know
they always say hindsight's you know
2020 it's always 100% accurate um we had
this facilitated Retreat once uh dude's
name is Colin card he's kind of
invisible in the business space but he's
one of the
best managers of entrepreneurs and
coaches to try to get the best out of
you and your business and we've spent
multi- days with this guy several times
in a business Forum that I was in many
many years ago uh this is Circa 2010 to
2013 or so um and one of the most
valuable lessons that I took away from
some of the Retreats and some of the
times that we were working together
these were like small groups of like
seven to eight guys and a couple of gals
in one of the forums that I was in um
where you get to know each other very
well you break bread you know each
other's families you know you know um
you know their husbands and wives and
you know stuff like that their
boyfriends girlfriends uh you get to
know them really well so you're in this
environment where you're being built up
it's usually Retreat there's nobody
around phones are off sort of [__] and
it was
like paying attention to your gut and
listening to it one of the things that
came up there was a guy you know I can
share the story because I can uh water
down and sort of like make it vague to
get the point across but there was a guy
that was dealing with a employee who was
a problem and he was continuously being
problematic he was he was zigging when
he was saying zag it's like if you're
with a chick and you set a boundary and
you say look I don't deal with women you
know she's obviously saying hey Rich
take your V Where Do We Stand are we in
a relationship you know I don't want to
share you blah blah blah you say fine
that's cool but I noticed that you know
you're friends with one of your exes and
I I can't take a chick seriously that
deals with one of her exes so if that's
a problem for you I just don't see this
working out okay so you know she lets
you know the ex go but if she keeps
hanging out with them right or keeps
meeting up with them keeps texting
doesn't even meet up with them but keeps
texting stays in communication that's a
boundary you know that's that's a line
in the sand that you've set that is your
bottom line line and if they cross it
then that's re room for dismissal same
thing with this guy that I was working
with in this business form he had this
trouble he has a problem employee he
kept crossing the bottom line he kept
pushing into it kept causing Havoc drama
manufactured indignation and the
question then became when do you fire
somebody you know is it an evaluation
process is it how much money they make
you in that business what do they do
what are their tasks who do they know
how long they've been with you what's it
going to cost you to package them off
and surprisingly the answer we always
came back to which solved the problem
and it's usually the simplest thing in
the world was as soon as you realize
they need to go it's as simple as that
when do you fire somebody as soon as you
realize they need to go AKA hire slowly
fire quickly people get hired for the
resume they get hired for their ability
they get hired for their skills or as
they hold out to the public that they
have and slowly over time as you watch
their behavior and how they interact
with people and what they do and who
they hang out with and all that sort of
stuff they'll tell you who they are and
if you discover who they are is not who
you want on board on in your
relationship in your business in your
friendships whatever happened happens to
be it doesn't matter the minute that you
realize that they're not a good fit
that's when you get rid of them and the
sooner you can get to that point the
sooner you can get rid of people that
are anchors in your life that are
problematic that are going to expose you
to risk
uh that uh betray bottom lines that you
set you know one of the one of the rules
that I set for myself and people that I
collaborate with is I don't work with
losers and I don't work with people that
work with
losers so I'll say that again I don't
work with losers and I don't work with
people that work with losers so if I
identify a group a company an
organization whatever it happens to be
that I don't agree with their mission
how they operate uh what they do for
business what they're selling what their
services with their product it doesn't
matter and it's them there's always the
US versus them Dynamic Jack Donovan
talks about it um I've mentioned his
books before I don't have them here in
front of me to wave in front of you but
Jack Donovan talks about the notion of
US versus them there's an Empire of
nothing out there that they're trying to
build for us the globalists want us all
to be all inclusive everybody take your
jab stand on your dots get all scared
about some [__] you know trending new
thing change your Facebook social media
avatars because you're standing with
whoever standing with whatever flag
whatever cause whatever the [__] it is
that they want you to care about the
Empire of nothing right and the reality
of the world is that's not how things
have worked throughout history it's
always been US versus them okay so
Define who us is draw a perimeter around
us and then Define who them are and keep
them on the outside you don't want them
to stop eating feeding themselves
whatever I I want them to eat just not
at my table so you have to Define these
things for for yourself this is how you
keep your life simple this is how you
keep your life productive this is how
you avoid chaos and drama and
unnecessary issues in your life in your
business and in your relationship is
being fastidious with these lines that
you draw in the sand and you tell these
people you tell these women that you're
that you're with you tell these people
that you're in business with you tell
employees that you have you tell
employers you know doesn't matter what
it happens to be if there's a line in
the sand that you draw which is your
bottom line draw it state it and let
them know why and if they cross it you
fire them you fire their ass right I
already told you I don't hang out with
chicks that you know keep men around
from their past so what's it going to be
because you can't keep hanging out with
Bill right like you guys are porking for
years you were engaged some doesn't
matter whatever it happens to be you
don't even have to explain yourself just
State your you know you make the
statement a fact and it is what it is
and if that's the choice that you're
going to make then I know the choice
that I have to make you know it's as
simple as that so they can't ever be
confused upset with you oh I was
mistreated I can't believe that you know
he did that you [__] told them what
you were going to do before you did it
right so again high or slow watch their
behavior see what they're all about size
them up and if they cross your bottom
line if they don't fit you fire them I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out